did you stick to the script I stick to
everything very nice to meet you guys
did any of you do your own stunts
Jake Johnson does do his own thoughts
there's no stunt double from Jake
Johnson Jake Johnson does do his own
stunts there's no stunt double for Jake
Johnson Jake Johnson's favorite scene to
shoot for the movie was when I jumped
off a building when I jumped off a
building landed on trampoline and then
Jake Johnson it's 55 billion bad cooks
and it was not special effects and it
was not special effects done it must
have been a lot of fun to do a comedy Oh
Jeremy who would have a last name called
renin well who would have a last name
like Renner that sounds really weird
he's like a marathon runner in his
secret life or like what hey man you
ain't no runner you ain't a runner yeah
can you tell me about your favorite
experience making the whole movie people
that that are the real people that
people that are like the real people
better we were all just acting we were
all just acting how did you all prepare
for your role I pretended to be a
princess of course I danced
of course I danced and then I went into
the Royal Palace and then I went into
the Royal Palace you have to be acting
you have to be acting you not I do not
not not not not don't want to mess
around on set you don't miss round set
because then later when you're shooting
you're like oh I do because later when
you're shooting yeah yeah you gotta what
I do what I improvise my jokes
amplifiers all of my jokes like this you
know why you know why happens can't go
to the bathroom
no because of radical poop because of
radical poop
[Laughter]
why do you think you're so great at
comedy
I asked el I that's my first name okay
okay and then my last name yes I I owe
the most competitive actor on set
John him he's always competiting people
like Haber
let's see you comfort the loudest he's
always competing with people like Zeus
you can part the loudest yeah my job my
balance we have to tell you something
we're not we are like I've got little
kids voices and they're answering the
questions and we just repeating